foreign
gets it back Matthews and Marner the penalty
Killers norlander shoot scores hits somebody
in front to beat Samson up and there's a
power play goal for Montreal oh no Linder
does an excellent job at just making sure this one
gets through and Kirby docks does a nice job of
getting into the odd goggle on the way or Brody
in front but could pass on the backhand back to
the point and here the the key is oh yeah right
off the knee there of McCabe as McCabe tried to
play goaltender instead he gets a piece of
it and look at Samson offers there to make
the save and the cave with that deflection goes
back well pumps back ahead Caufield at the line
moves in along with Suzuki jumping up with got
by him and now Crager starts back the other ways
surprises Allen and the game inside
another example of the guy getting an opportunity
coming in on a PTO all kinds of pressure watch the
fake hit there by Anderson and a quick little
pass by Reeves but this is one just around the
stickman he's able to get it through and
underneath the glove I think Gregor has
been given every chance to try to find a place on
this lineup and he could see the reaction of Alan
Matthews against Mayu Mayu knocked
him down loose Puck fruit for two
seats here for Tuesday in front
Bruce Carter had his stick lifted
across a big shot by Matthews blocked by Pearson
got his own Rebound in front tomorrow [Applause]
well I mentioned there's his office for
tomorrow scored so many of his goals last
year from in tight but a couple of great
plays here but watch his poison a nice
little soccer pass here kicks out for the
one-timer gets blocked then he gets right
back on it curls it to the inside and a
little sauce if being able to put it to
an area as Tavares was going to pull this one
across he kind of lost control for a second and
Brody snuck in behind
Sam Lafferty is a good goal for Mitch murder and
entertaining golfer Chris Cuthbert and Gregson and
Sean who would get to get involved in a parking
lot dust up like low pick it's all what you do
with it and he's done a wonderful job of getting
himself into a position to play a significant role
here this year there's Jack guy swinging wide
a backhand that's Hampton I've got a piece of
Harris Under duress Lafferty Tavares nice enough
by Allen and a good one with nice great Outlet
by Matthews and Away goes Marner slavkowski in
slipstream Marner holds on he finds Matthews
Island a terrific play all round here's
the play deep in the zone no look pass
by Matthews to Marner marner's gonna attack all
the attention there he takes a quick look knows
exactly where Margaret Matthews is going to be
so Tavares returns leaps back in full strength
one shot on the power play for Montreal in
one spectacular save short-handed [Applause]
as Alan brought Matthews Here Comes Toby
nylander couldn't get it Billy scores [Music]
kept the Play Alive now it's William nylander
with the turnover in the neutral zone goby's
trying to give it back to him this one goes to
the skate and right back onto the team for goalie
the credit for Domi here this is a play that a lot
of guys put down low and don't get it up and over
leaps operating under the direction of e Boucher
on this power play Riley shooting loose Perkins
you stick on that under a half
minute remaining in the second period
dock out to the Penalty kill
roll causes a turnover it'll
be Monahan getting it back Sean want
to hit in and only scores [Applause]
a composure for Monahan there just staring
down samsonov is looking like he's gonna
shoot just the end of a long power play here
all of a sudden a minute and a half in maybe
not the intensity a lost draw now Riley's
not able to close the gap two men watching
the team and this is a two-on-one Down
Low let's just look at the patience of
Monahan you know from the goaltender's
perspective look at how long [Applause]
before we could save maybe 60 40 chance if
this was 1993 I can guarantee you it might be
100 there there would be a fight in this third
period kept Alive by Tavares and now it's Lee
Crusher the captain in front of Sam Lafferty
batted that waist high and able to connect
with nice Tavares can't get that shot through
Edwards wanting to clear it it'll be kept in by
the Leafs a pass to willinger [Applause] [Music]
for over two minutes and John Tavares has number
two on the night elbow able to get across but a
desperation attempt to clear it doesn't factor
in and now look at all the white sweaters just
standing still Alex comes flying across thinking
it's going to be a hard one-timer watched a
little bit the knuckleball there by Tavares
but I actually think it helped them I think the
glove them Jack guy stepped up on Dolby looked
like he might have been nicked on the flight
but Domi continues on almost needed these that
shot scores [Applause] back within one the cycle
of Life doc fighting here with coconut and then
there's the shot from the point I think it hit
the right off the pad as this one's coming through
knuckleballer off the skate of coconut and right
through the legs of samsonov he wasn't able to
get out high enough this is a back foot one timer
that knocks around his feet move so quickly as do
his hands it's hard for the goaltender to judge
when the shot is gonna come there's Gallagher
knocking it down and imana had had a look if we
need one badly who are the guys who are going
to step to the Forefront and get it happening
Here Comes nice to the net that Allen stops
that in tight and it'll come back to norlanders
good reach to hold it in Lafferty challenges
Garfield Suzuki trying to get away from Brody
Kirby dock watch by nice SWAT Anderson scores
he's able to handle the pressure and then
how about this catch and release final 10
seconds here at regulation time Anderson's
third of the preseason Matthews [Applause]
what a play by Matthews who nearly won it
Suzuki car field and Harris [Applause]
three on three to decide proceedings and Nick
Suzuki back in his own Zone Caulfield winds it
up working against Lillard turn back against Lila
grin looks for the captain and hands It Off field
s the Canadians have won it
a goal in the final minute to tie it
and a goal of 31 seconds of overtime
as Montreal avoids a preseason sweep